welcome to this video playing Nico
French the French lucky at least it is
unless this is snow yeah well sometimes
you have those flecks that then look
like if a particular one and then it is
kind of I don't know the French I don't
know French Bermudez or something which
is probably not existing but you get you
get the point something quite quite
similar but not the same okay
the Dutch defense anyway French play the
Dutch defense do they I don't know this
this Frenchman played the Dutch defense
okay I guess chicken but a six this is
the kind of setup that they normally
yeah prefer to take
hmm it's not nice I don't want to give
up the bishop but I have to
I really have to yeah I have to get some
kind of activity otherwise it's not good
with the playing against the the bishop
pair I can maybe just take play Queen f6
for Queen f5 nobody plays in a more
enterprising way very interesting
so taking here or this cannot be that
bad relief okay so I came to give the
check the fan with a like I can take 1
g6 but this does not look right does not
look like a sufficient compensation
Bishop takes h6
I don't believe ok so I'm just going to
drop back
keeping this attacked here I have a
check temple move you know I could match
you five come on or not jabya nice to go
to H head now yeah but okay this is
probably still not totally clear it was
a totally unnecessary for him to allow
it but anyway you're not really
considering to take right okay let's
check just briefly this kind of the
chicken it's not doing any good right so
you have to do that yeah he can take
stairs some way to punish that rook see
one maybe whoopsy wonderful look she's
seven but look see one is got Bishop
cheeks as well
okay let's let's start with this one
provoking g51 thing that i just only now
recognize I thought you could see one
he has Bishop b3 but I am actually
covering this with the Queen so this
makes rook c1 from much more interesting
idea
so c1 Queen d3 I can also take on c7 hmm
so then this is probably a good good
move
quinces seven was my idea
is there any better
yeah it's not it's not totally clear how
how good it really is but let's do it
there should be three a queen bee seven
maybe
I'm a rookie is not playing absolutely
not
queen bee 78
I don't know ah difficult stuff you can
also just go back now here to me five or
to d5
yeah can't castle though and I
definitely will
I'm glad that I get this look into the
game okay to see seven or here maybe
here for rook c5 possibly now I think
this is okay now for me before I wasn't
sure
yeah trying to be as active as possible
and we'll see seven would be very nice
to get in yeah
we can I can take him
I know about taking lime okay I'm going
to definitely trade off this bishop
which is a very important piece
the main defender of the king and also
possible supporter of an apron that
check it might appear fattening rook c7
I'm not sure if it is a threat down I'm
really not clear
check yeah I know Ange and I know I
shouldn't trade but I don't see how to
how to win this and with Queens on this
is probably a draw but it is least I can
play some quick moves check
yeah that's even winning now I think
Jack bones do a very good job
f7 was even better of course check
checkmate huh
okay Wow
yeah that was a difficult game even
after this this King h7 it was a very
unclear position I mean after King h8 I
really have no idea what's going on
he's got potentially very good activity
in the center of it maybe I can may I
can fight for the e4 square 92 trying to
put it here yeah this was really just a
blunder but it is not it's not easy and
probably I should just Castle yeah what
I did now with allowing this Queen d3
business this is maybe okay but but now
Castle okay I compute that points out
Queen g6 that's that's possible but this
is this is not cleared or this position
and here well yeah the computer actually
agrees with me for once
Queen B 5 gives black very decent plane
a difficult position when I play without
the rook here you know but computers has
equal but it's they're very difficult
for white to play and here after that I
could Castle and I think yeah I'm better
some somewhat better at least and at the
end I managed to win it after some
inches okay well thanks for watching